what did China know and when did it know
it a new report shows the corona virus
outbreak could have been contained by
95% if the communist regime acted sooner
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo pushing
for answers saying if we do not figure
out where China went wrong we could face
another crippling pandemic in the future
and President Trump addressed the
cover-up earlier well there were much
better if we had known about this a
number of months earlier it could have
been contained to that one area in China
where it started and certainly the world
is paying a big price for what they did
Jesse well the first case of coronavirus
surfaced in mid-november that's four
months ago and when the scientists
identified the virus the Chinese
government told him to destroy the
samples and they gagged the scientists
and told him to lie about it then they
allowed these wet markets where the
contamination started to remain open
they told the w-h-o world health
organization that it was not contagious
human-to-human they allowed the New
Year's celebration in Wuhan 11 million
people to go on everybody drinking and
eating and having a great time together
and that was a colossal mistake then
they allowed thousands of Chinese
citizens to fly all over the country the
Chinese government dragged its feet in
releasing data to the rest of the world
on this and when the Trump
administration offered to send US
scientists to one gone to investigate
and help they said no you're not allowed
so now when they say oh the US military
they were the ones that planted the
virus in Wuhan and they say we're going
to withhold drugs from the United States
during the pandemic that's just crazy
and the fact that the president calls it
the Chinese virus he just wants to make
sure that there's a little
accountability and truth to what
happened Juan Jesse I think you're miss
reading the room you're supposed to be a
happy show today I'm talking about the
Chinese things up
blame the president instead of the
Chinese communist government no I Know
Who I elected okay so here's the thing
yeah you elected president Trump yeah
that's right that's my president that's
what they say first speak about it but I
won't say Chinese commie
we have time we have time we're gonna
have time for after-action reports I
think it's inevitable we're gonna have a
9/11 Commission style review of what
happened so we will be able to know
exactly what happened and where this
came from I think it's so important but
I want to underline something that you
said which is something actually senator
Rubio and others have said which is that
we are so reliant on the Chinese right
now we have I believe it's Governor
Cuomo of New York over in China trying
to look at them in terms of whether or
not they have ventilators that they can
sell us to help our hospitals we are
reliant on them in terms of our
prescription drugs delivered in large
part from China and so when they get
vengeful or angry or whatever you know
we have to somehow step in and say you
know what this is too much we can come
back and make some of these things in
the United States and that's actually
what president Trump's tried to do over
the last three years is extricate
ourselves from from our reliance on
China as a manufacturing hub but Gregg
what do you say I as a member of the
media I am absolutely disgusted how
we're saying these negative things about
China I mean I just can't believe I mean
really that's racist this entire segment
is racist because we're pointing out the
disease with the diseases origins and we
should be ashamed of ourselves with
dealing in facts
that's awful my suggestion I actually
agree with Juan let's we need to turn
our focus away from blaming people and
make a list of the people who need to
pay and six months from now we go back
and we look at the list because right
now I want to get people well I want to
find the to find the treatments and do
all the good stuff and you know what
screwed screw the Chinese government
we'll deal with him later but day now
point out that the China jessie was
mentioning is waging a disinformation
campaign on social media platforms that
her
created in the US that their own
citizens don't see but we certainly do
that's why I actually think we have to I
think we have to fight that part now the
after-action report on all our actions
and think yeah we can say that for later
but I would not rest on these propaganda
pieces we should try to get as much
information there as possible
authoritarian regimes that's how this
kind of thing happens you had
journalists there that were trying
Chinese journalists they were trying to
raise the alarm they're the ones that
were put in jail they're the ones who
were rounded up they're the ones who are
now trying to use emojis and Morse code
in order to get around the censors
because they're worried about it
I think we need a lot more of a push of
social media into that country we've got
to talk to the younger people of China
because the propaganda war that is a
serious one and the only way to really
deal with it is to have a lot of truth
and if we don't hold China accountable
for this now you know it's gonna happen
again and it could be worse next time